[Music]
since the murder of george floyd
individuals and organizations have been
forced to take a hard look
at how they think about diversity equity
and inclusion
dei and there are some competing
theories as to how we should do that
chloe valderri has some ideas that are
different
to many of the standard ways in which
it's being discussed
hers starts with love
this is a bit of optimism
[Music]
chloe thanks so much for joining me i do
appreciate it sure
i want to have an honest conversation
with you
since the murder of george floyd the
significance of dei in our workplace has
become
amplified and for good reason and a lot
of organizations are
forced and a lot of not just
organizations i think a lot of us
are forced to take a look at ourselves
and our communities and our companies
and how we
organize them and lead them and a lot of
companies are seeking help
from dei practitioners to help them
do better i understand it's not a new
industry but it's a growing industry
and i would argue still
figuring itself out for sure and from
the stories that i'm hearing
some of it isn't working as intended
it's
either creating more division
or creating backlash
i've heard in some cases i read about
you in an article in the atlantic i read
about your work
and you had a very different point of
view
about how uh dei
is currently and dare i say
traditionally normally
being trained and that's why i wanted to
talk to you
because i was really inspired by your
point of view
so i guess the first question is how did
you come to your point of view
because your point of view is different
than the norm i suppose i should
say what my point of view is it's
probably a good starting point yes
in order to answer that question i guess
when it comes to
specifically tackling the issue of
racism
and combating racism and to be precise
by combating racism i mean combating
supremacist ways of thinking
my understanding is that supremacist
ways of thinking are actually
fundamentally informed by an inferiority
complex
within the human beings who hold those
supremacist ways of thinking whether
that stems from a feeling of a lack of
self-worth
or a lack of belonging or a lack of a
sense of meaning which are all
experiences that we can all fall into
just by virtue of being human
but the way they can manifest when it
comes to this topic
negatively is in the supremacist way of
thinking
and so you know i have an anti-racism
firm called theory of enchantment and we
do training
but our training is rooted in the idea
that you have to actually give people
a self-refinement practice in order to
deal with all the things
that are part of the human condition
that make you susceptible to that
overcompensating impulse
whether that's fear of imperfection
whether that's dealing with
vulnerability
dealing with mortality dealing with
baggage
all of these things again are natural to
the human condition
so the idea behind that is if you can be
equipped with a
practice that will enable you to have a
healthy and holistic relationship with
yourself
first then you will be able to be open
be radically curious about difference
and
translate that love and compassion that
you have for the self
to the other how is dei currently
implemented or trained that that makes
your point of view different
well i'd say there are different types
of trainings out there
but one that has certainly reached more
popularity in the in the last year
is a kind of training that
isn't really based on the inner
psychology of the human being
it simply says that if you are white
then
you by definition engage in
quote-unquote whiteness
you have to atone for your whiteness
this might take the form
of people being encouraged to
self-segregate in trainings
and speak about their experiences
whether if they're black or if they're
white
this may take the form of what some
people have called struggle sessions
and getting white people to sort of
admit to their privilege and
admit to how they have perpetuated
advantages over disadvantaged
individuals
part of the problem with that approach
is that it actually
runs the risk of increasing that
insecurity
that we spoke about about among both
blacks and whites quite frankly
and it is again that insecurity that is
fodder for
the impulse to overcompensate which
feeds right into supremacist ways of
thinking
in the first place so by making us feel
insecure
we're actually feeding the beast exactly
and so what you're proposing as an
alternative
is to instead of viewing the room as
black and white
is to view everybody in the room as
human beings who all
struggle with issues of insecurity
inadequacy belonging the list goes on
yeah of what we all struggle with and
helping us look inside and say this is
who i am and coming to terms
with that how does that then translate
to improving race relations
the idea is that if you have a much more
healthy relationship with yourself
if you're able to deal healthily
with all the things that trip you up
let's say someone is rude towards you
and instead of instead of seeing that
rudeness as oh you're being rude this is
wrong
you actually start to internalize that
because you've recognized that something
within you
is also capable of rudeness and it has
also been rude in the past
right so then you so then you are
triggered by that and then you start to
other that person and then you start to
condescend to that person
so the idea is that by becoming aware of
your own
complexity and your own capacity for
good and evil your own capacity
for joy and despair all these things
exist within you you'll be less likely
to
otherwise people and to condescend to
them because you will also recognize the
complexity that exists within them
hard question for you go ahead i am
drawn to your work
because my work very much centers around
love and community and finding common
ground
in your opinion what is it
about the way that dei is predominantly
taught today
that became more popular now than your
point of view
like why isn't it the other way around
well i quite frankly
honestly don't think most people engage
with
the writings and the
thinking of individuals like dr king and
james baldwin we tend to pay lip service
to these individuals
i mean james baldwin has some
controversial statements certainly
statements that would be controversial
in light of today's
in vogue diversity approaches but
instead of seriously wrestling with that
we might memorize a quote or two
but we aren't actually challenged by
their ideas because
their ideas were radical what are some
of the more important lessons
that baldwin and king shared that have
informed this point of view for you
well one of the important things was
this notion that
if you are a survivor of racial
oppression and i say survivor
not victim because baldwin actually said
i have been mistreated i am not a victim
i have been mistreated
dr king taught that if you were a
survivor of racial oppression
you specifically were susceptible to
falling into a spirit of revenge
and to falling into a spirit of
resentment and to falling into a spirit
of self-righteousness
and so you had to be on guard with
yourself
to guard yourself against that tendency
so many of the protesters who went out
to protest during the civil rights
movement
before they went to protest they would
ask themselves am i harboring a spirit
of resentment am i harboring a spirit of
self-righteousness
if so i'm not going to go out and
protest today because the person who is
engaging
in racist behavior is still my brother
is still my sister
and i don't want to project anything
that's going to add
to the suffering that my oppressor is
experiencing
if someone is feeling so worthless
that they feel they have to claim that
they are better than another person
because of their skin color
then that person is suffering right and
that's a very also different language
that was used then that we don't really
talk about today um but the idea is like
when i protest
i'm going to attempt to protest with
absolute love
flowing through me and if i'm not in the
headspace if i'm not in a spirit where
that's possible
then i'm not going to protest so that's
a very hard
again radical in the and i think the
true meaning of the word
work can you tell me a specific story
where
you saw this transformation take place
where you saw the introspection happen
even begrudgingly i can give you a story
uh specifically that i know about a guy
who practiced these
ideas daryl davis so daryl davis is an
african-american man who's brilliant
musician that's his first claim to fame
but his second claim to fame is that he
successfully got
hundreds of members of the kkk to leave
the kkk
and he did this by painstakingly
deciding to be
in community with these individuals
right to engage them to essentially wear
them down
right and to continue to be in community
with these individuals even though they
didn't like him because of his skin
color
and by doing that for long periods of
time
this inevitably created an identity
crisis on the part of these men
because their ideology told them one
thing about black people
but their experience showed them
something else and the outcome of that
of course
was over 200 members and eventually
ended up leaving the organization
the kkk now in order for daryl davis to
be able to do this
it required that daryl davis know
himself
and understand his own self-worth he had
such a
you know strong sense of worthiness that
it didn't matter
what they told him in the beginning it
didn't matter what they said to him
it just went through him essentially it
didn't even affect him that's why the
theory of entertainment starts out
with the understanding that you the
practitioner have to understand your
self-worth
and you have to move from that place
because if that
is insecure there'll be all kinds of
actions
that you'll take to feel a sense of
worthiness
and some of those actions may be held
unhealthy and detrimental to you
and detrimental to others many would
argue
that it is not for the person who is the
survival of abuse
to have to then be the one to
look at themselves do the hard work of
introspection
to then do the hard work of learning to
withstand
additional abuse to over time
to be able to create the cognitive
dissonance like there's been enough
hard work quote unquote uh being
the survivor of abuse i we shouldn't
have to now
do more to help them fix their problem
this
is an interesting kind of language
and way of thinking i've certainly been
exposed to by individuals who bring this
up in some of my classes
that language doesn't quite fall on my
ear
in a in a meaningful way because it
still
somehow seems to perpetuate the illusion
of separation
that it that we have in our minds
between ourselves and the other
right and you know what i would agree
with you it's not your
responsibility to reach out it's not
your responsibility to try and change
that person or to try to influence that
person
but all i can tell you is that i know
something a little bit about human
nature
and this approach is kind of an
evolutionary hack
against falling into a spiral of
vengeance and that's what we have to be
on the lookout
for as human beings that's the only
other alternative that i see to this
and again it's not simply about holding
people accountable for their actions
it's a problem because when we start to
other people
when we start to say to ourselves oh i
could never do that
right i could never see myself in a
position where i would treat someone
like that
that's not that's not possible for me to
do that
which is a delusion because every single
human being on earth
is capable of that i just have seen
human history play itself out
uh into revenge counter-event revenge
council revenge
and i think it's super necessary that we
avoid that you said a term
the illusion of separation
can you unwrap that for me i'm still
trying to unwrap it myself
okay so so take off a couple of pieces
of the paper then
i think it goes back to the first
principle of the theory of enchantment
which is treat people like human beings
not political abstractions
and when we go over this in the workshop
we talk about kendrick lamar's line
where he says i got power poison pain
and joy inside my dna
and we talk about how every single
person has this
has this complexity of emotions
and psychology and neurobiology
every single human being this is what
makes us human and we speak about how
if your social psychological needs
aren't met
if you are experiencing a lack of a
sense of belonging whether it's at home
whether it's with your friends whether
it's
out in the street professional life etc
if you don't have a sense of connection
with others then that can create a void
in your life
and that void can be filled with
extremist ways of thinking
because extremist groups will come to
you and exploit your insecurities and
tell you oh
you want something to belong to we'll
give you something to belong to
you want something to believe in we'll
give you something to believe in there
is
no psychological difference between the
way a gang
recruits young men and the way white
nationalist groups
recruit young people or individuals in
general it's the same psychology
so when i say this illusion of
separation what i'm really trying to get
to
is the fact that this potential
exists within every single one of us
and we need to be able to stop and
recognize that
and this is a part by the way of
ultimately recognizing
the awesomeness the vastness of what it
means to be human
which means containing the potential to
do both good
and bad and there's a kind of arrogance
in
assuming that because you look a certain
way right
or because you are a certain gender or
whatever that you're incapable somehow
of falling into these
cycles you're not because you're human
so you're very capable
and so to be able to say to your brother
your sister
your behavior is wrong right but i'm
separating you
from your behavior because i know that i
too if i were to find myself in a
certain context in a certain situation
could fall into that same thought
pattern that produced that behavior
so that's what i'm getting at when i
when i talk about the illusion of
separation
do you want to know why i think your
work will not be
the norm oh god silence please no no
trust me i want it to be i'm a fan of
your point of view
and you're sharing a perspective with me
that i that i love but i think the
reason
your work will not become the standard
replacing what the standard is now
is because your work is difficult
and it's the same reason why
the vast majority of the population
are not in shape it's because working
out and eating well
is difficult and the reason why
a lot of people in america don't have
savings is because saving
is difficult and spending is much easier
and fun
and eating chocolate cake is much easier
and fun
and i'm not equating that the other work
is more fun
but it is easier your work is forcing
someone to face their own demons
look inside take themself on and you
you rightfully said this is hard work
you're starting people on a journey that
has to last their entire life
i guess the question i'm left with is
how do we help that
spread of the work become even if it's
imperfect normalized the theory of
enchantment is
heavily influenced by the arts
and by pop culture and i think that
there is something you know we talk
about the
problematic challenging aspects of
american society but i also think that
there's wisdom
and hidden gems of wisdom in our in our
artistic culture
that we can sort of revivify or use to
revivify
these conversations when i bring up
kendrick lamar in the context
of this kind of a training when i bring
up
you know maya angelou when i bring up
james baldwin these are individuals that
are still
looked up to even if in an albeit
superficial way
right so if i can if i can probe people
to dig deeper to look harder
uh i i think we have a chance that's all
there's obviously no guarantee there's
never a guarantee
but we have to we have to give ourselves
a chance i hope that there's some people
listening in right now
who are running organizations leading
organizations and some or leading a team
who want to do this work who struggle to
do this work
i know of a few who have gone down
what you and i are calling the the more
accepted or standard path
and had it blow up in their face and now
once bit and twice shy
don't know what next step to take who
are looking for some specific
steps that they can take that may be
different than the ones they've tried
can you please share whether it's you
know comes directly from the theory of
enchantment
or or otherwise something specific
that we can and should do
i would say to practice shadow work what
is what is shadow work
so the shadow is a term popularized by
the psychologist carl jung who is who
has a heavy influence on the work of the
theory of enchantment
um the idea is that the shadow is
everything that you do not like about
yourself
that you repress and you project onto
other people
so i'll take a simple case of
basic racism someone's racist towards
you
someone says something to you or insults
you because of your skin color
there's a difference between viewing
that person and seeing what they've just
done
as unacceptable harmful behavior wrong
behavior
right there's a difference between
saying you need to be you need to not do
that we need to be held accountable for
that if it becomes more than
you know an insult um there's a
difference between
that and having your ego be triggered by
that
right when your ego is triggered that
means that you have begun to
otherwise that person and you have begun
to
basically uh see yourself as better than
that person as above that person
and then you become affected by
superiority complex and then you start
to look down
so the way you do shadow work is you
basically practice identifying people
that you don't like identify the
behavior that they engage in
that you don't like and then you
identify that behavior within you
oh and that shadow works all right you
and you practice it
all right i'm doing it in my head right
now
[Laughter]
thinking of someone i don't like the
behavior that i don't like
so this is about criticizing the
behavior not the person this is being
able to separate the behavior from the
person
so instead saying i don't like that
person i'm trying to identify
the behavior that i don't like i'm
de-personalizing it
and then that way i can see that
behavior in myself and then say okay
i'm reacting to myself in reacting to
them that's the basis of shadow work
exactly and if you do that over time and
i've i've practiced this
you find that you are you are less
triggered your ego is less
triggered by someone who is doing
something that you don't like where you
can just
you know speak to them in a way that is
reflective of the second principle of
the theory of enchantment which is
criticized to uplift and empower never
to tear down or destroy
criticize to uplift and empower never to
tear down and destroy give me a specific
example
i i have to tell you the truth i'm super
in the past i'm less triggered by it now
but in the past i have been triggered by
people who are
in my workshops who say things
that are definitely emblematic of that
popular way of training go on please
please to be specific so they will say
things like
i just want to acknowledge that most of
us in this room are white
again still perpetuating the illusion of
separation
between they still can't see that that
the people in the room
are sort of part of the beloved
community that dr king spoke about that
they can't see the people in their the
room as essentially family members
they're still being
fixated on skin color so i've i've had
those experiences
and how did it trigger you i i felt it
physically like i know when i'm
triggered because i feel
it physically in like my gut anger is
anger
like this person is annoying this person
is like
what previous training did this person
take like this person is just spewing
nonsense or things that they heard
online
or just like repeat reciting
propositions whatever
and and then i began to like other that
person
right i began to see that person in my
mind as less than
right i remember i stopped myself and i
was like i was like wait a minute chloe
you have totally said things in the past
that were off-putting so you have also
engaged in this kind of behavior so why
are you acting like this is like a
foreign thing
this is like a non-human thing you have
engaged in this behavior
this behavior is very human she's still
your sister
so you might think she's wrong and and i
did think she was wrong but that's
different
from engaging her on the level of again
that beloved community
versus being triggered by it and then
starting to otherize that person
what's the language of of uplifting
criticism
versus destructive criticism you know if
you would have criticized me or someone
else destructively
what does that sound like like it's just
me saying that you're trash
right it's like you're trash and you'll
always you're like
you know you're you're trashing it will
always be trash you always wear trash
okay all your family right all right
and what's uplifting criticism what does
that sound like
a blessing criticism sounds like listen
what you did was wrong but i'm telling
you this because i care
about you because i know that you're
capable of so much more you have so much
potential
and i'm not telling you guys to tear you
down i'm telling you this because i love
you
because i care about you that's
uplifting
how does how does one respond to that if
it comes across as condescending
so the way it doesn't come across as
condescending is you acknowledge that
times that you've acted like that
uh okay but you say it listen i've done
the same thing
i'm not speaking you know out of turn
i've also
done this and i felt really bad
afterwards so i'm not telling you this
you know i'm not telling you this random
i've also engaged in similar kind of
behavior so i know how it
can make me feel powerful in the moment
and then i feel really crappy later
so that's how you that's how you
actually give someone psychological
safety to hear that criticism is about
being vulnerable and so bringing
yourself down to the same level which is
i'm not better than you i am of you i we
we are we are both messy human beings
you have these three principles of
enchantment can you just
go through what the three principles are
please yes so the three principles of
the theory of enchantment are number one
treat people like human beings not
political abstractions
number two criticize to uplift and
empower
never to tear down or destroy and number
three try to root
everything you do in love and compassion
i want to go back to principle number
one can you give me a specific example
of a situation
that any of us might find ourselves in
uh
where we are able to treat someone like
a human being and not a
political abstraction i feel like the
first principle is primarily about
having people
explore what it means to be human which
is to say
that you're not fixed you're not simply
a caricature so if you engage
in a good behavior one day that doesn't
mean you're perpetually angelic
and if you engage in bad behavior
another day that doesn't mean you're
demonic right i think the first
principle is understanding the
complexity that exists within human
beings and
speaking to that in general not
necessarily
um trying to address a problem but
having that be the lens with which you
approach everything so whether it's
republican democrat whether it's uh race
issues
just seeing everyone with the fullness
of their humanity
and their complexity as opposed to like
putting people in boxes
and stereotyping them and saying that
you are only one thing
as opposed to a whole a whole host of
things let's go to principle three
root everything you do in love and
compassion that's probably the hardest
one isn't it
well the truth is principle number three
is actually a culmination of the first
two principles so once you get
once you get to principle three you you
realize that you've actually been
learning how to do the work of loving
uh yourself and others with and treating
yourself and others with compassion
fundamentally your work actually has
nothing to do with race
your work is teaching human beings how
to be better human beings
it so happens that we we live in a time
where uh race is
the door that is showing us
that maybe we're not acting like the
versions of human beings we want to act
like
or be like and in another time it might
have been something else
but in this time race is that is that
opening that forces us
to ask ourselves difficult questions and
go on the journey
it sounds that's what it sounds like and
in so doing in doing this
work of introspection and viewing
yourself and how we view others and
how we treat others ultimately it should
benefit not only
how we interact with people who look
differently than us but who think
differently than us
who have difficult political points of
view in us who
have a different interpretation of what
the world should look like
i mean it it's so it should improve the
quality of our friendships of our
romantic relationships i mean this work
you're doing is about
human beings getting along better with
other human beings
it just so happens that race is the
forum for which this work
can begin i think that's right i think
it it goes through the particular to
show the universal
um it's interesting because you know if
you if you go through the full
the full theory of enchantment course
it's very intergenerational
in the sense that there's stoicism in
there
but there's also the lion king in there
uh this this idea that
if you believe that there's certain uh
wisdom
teachings that are timeless then you
should expect to find them
across different time periods in many
different forms
um and we happened to teach narcissism
in both the marcus aurelius context but
also from the lion king
i basically designed theory of
enchantment to be able to speak across
time and to speak across history and
ultimately i hope that it will grow in
such a way that it can also speak across
cultures and speak across different
regions because that would be
actually really cool because what that
would mean is that we've unearthed
something
that is fundamental to the human
experience that can be found
across time culture and history and
that's that's pretty cool thing to
discover ultimately
i mean i mean as i'm listening to you
i'm thinking israel palestine
i'm thinking all of the protracted
conflicts around the world
that ultimately what we've done is
dehumanized each other
and the hard work is is seeing ourselves
in each other and seeing each other in
ourselves
which is what you're talking about so
that's hard this is hard work and that
is why it requires
practicing there's like a lot of
humility and and grace quite frankly
that one should show themselves
and to show others who are practicing
this work because it is it is
truly incredibly hard perhaps one of the
hardest things one will ever do
in their entire life can you tell me a
surprising change you've seen
in yourself or in your own relationships
or in your professional life
that you didn't expect but came from
this so i like to say that as human
beings
we tend to fluctuate between two modes
of thinking that are
inaccurate so we tend to think that we
are either omnipotent
everything is in our control or some
aspect of something is in our control
or we tend to think that we're impotent
we have absolutely no control
over anything and i was in a
relationship
last year where i was basically acting
impotent i was acting as if i was
completely powerless
um i was also acting as if the guy had
and he does um had infinite potential
and he does um
because everyone has infinite potential
but at the same time like
we just were not on the same energy
levels
um and i i had this it was drawn
out for far longer than it should have
been and i should have basically
split the difference between impotence
and omnipotence and say okay you don't
have all the power in the world but you
do have some power
in this situation so let's start leaning
into that power
and that's something that i learned
through
practicing theory of enchantment through
teaching theory of enchantment through
seeing how other people
respond to theory of enchantment and
that's that's something that i had to
i had to learn because part of me
struggles from the fact that just
because someone has
unlimited potential and they do doesn't
mean that i have to be the one
to be present and wait for it to
come to fruition and it might not come
to fruition that's the whole point of
potential right
so i had to learn that potential doesn't
mean
guarantee um but you still have
power to do things and to change the
situation if you want to
so that's something i had to learn in
the i did learn in the past year
i guess i have one more one more which
was
what set you on this journey in the
first place what happened
that you went this can't be right
this can't be the thing or the way okay
well i'm gonna try to sum this up for
you because there's a long story there
um so they basically i grew up in new
orleans
and i grew up in a very atypical
christian family
atypical in the sense that we did not
observe mainstream christian
holidays so we didn't celebrate
christmas or east or any of those things
instead we celebrated jewish holidays
like yom kippur
and and rosh hashanah and things of that
nature so this gave me an acute
sensibility towards jewish culture but
also an acute
allergy to anti-semitism which led to
in college i majored in international
studies
and i started being involved in the
israeli-palestinian conflict started
started doing
started hosting events around that space
and eventually discovered that
both of the communities were in many
cases
othering each other and would divulge
into
shouting matches in lecture halls and so
i asked myself
is there something that i can create
where the communities don't have to
agree with each other in the end
but they can actually agree that they're
going to live by these principles once
they enter into this
conversation with one another so that
was what i was wrestling with in college
i hadn't
had the answer yet and then i moved to
new york
a year afterwards and worked with wall
street journal
and worked on the thesis on this topic
but the thesis
went from how can i get people to
basically combat conflict to can i
actually teach people how to love
and then that became well in order to
teach people how to love
i have to actually ask well what are
people already in love with
and reverse engineer a framework to
teach people how to love based upon that
and simon people are in love with pop
culture
they are in love with brands like nike
and disney and beyonce these are brands
that
capture quasi-religious-like devotion
from their fans and i was like why what
is the common denominator
between all of these brands and i
researched it and the common denominator
was all these brands created
content where their audience saw
themselves and their potential
reflected back at them so from nike's
just do it
to the fact that almost every disney
movie is a motif for the human condition
an imperfect flawed individual
has to encounter a set of obstacles
challenges and emerge the hero
to beyonce when she says who run the
world girls
many women see themselves and their
potential reflected in that
right this is the common denominator so
i said to myself oh
all i have to do is create a framework
that does that same thing
and i will call it entrapment
in part because of guy kawasaki's book
enchantment which i was reading at the
time
but in part also because it was like wow
people
are gravitating towards things that show
them the fullness
of themselves and their potential i
found that incredibly enchanting
and really the idea of enchantment is
that we can become in
awe of the miracle that we are truly the
vast and wondrous miracle
uh that is a part of what it means to be
human and that
inc that entails being able to carry
both the tragedy and the beauty
of what it means to be human so i worked
for a non-profit for two years
the majority of that time was spent
giving lectures
on this new idea theory of enchantment
specifically as it related to the
israeli-palestinian conflict so i would
go over the three principles
but i would also sprinkle in pop culture
references that prove the three
principles
so i did that for two years and then
i uh got enough people being like you
know
this doesn't just apply to geopolitics
it applies to
interpersonal strife it applies to
social emotional learning in high
schools
why don't you consider like running with
this and creating your own
organization so in december of 2018
started the llc 2019 worked to transform
that 45-minute lecture into a full
training
business was slow not gonna lie business
was very slow in 2019
but i enjoyed the process of creating
that course
i got a few engagements speaking at high
schools primarily
my first engagement in the dei space was
actually with the civil rights
department
of the federal aviation authority uh and
in 2019
and then in 2020 everything happened the
way it happened
and i've been very fortunate to be able
to take the raven chairman to many new
audiences
and many new circles so i'm enjoying the
journey there's no guarantee
you know i i respect that i get that but
i'm enjoying being able to deliver this
and
also learn from the people who are in my
workshop learn with them
because they have something to teach me
as well that's
great that's magical i love how you show
up like a student
it's so crucial it's so important
especially in any space
where someone is brought in to teach or
instruct
or someone is introduced as an expert in
to the group the temptation is to
believe your own press
and to and to present yourself as the
expert
act like the expert for fear that others
will perceive you is not the expert
and the humility of showing up as the
student
is not only more inviting it's it's uh
people i think are much more open to
listen to you i wish more people
knew that to show up as a student rather
because it's easy to be a student right
because you can be wrong all the time
and you can say oh i didn't i didn't
know that
thank you for teaching me that you know
for sure
also showing up as a student is an
incredible antidote to
having your ego be triggered yeah if
you're showing up as a student then
you know and you're radically curious
then being wrong is no longer a threat
right being wrong is part of the journey
it's a part of the learning experience
thank you so much for taking the time
i'm so grateful i love what you're doing
and i really hope that your work becomes
the norm here's what i've learned
for race relations to improve in our
country all of us
all involved in the room have to go deep
inside ourselves to look at the things
that make us insecure
all of us have to be able to understand
we have said things to other people out
of anger
and desire to hurt ourselves
the only way that quote unquote they
will improve and fix themselves is if i
choose
to learn and work on myself
and i will never be fixed i will just
get better
in so doing i will serve as an example
for others too
and that's what makes a leader which is
i choose to do the work that i expect
you to do
beautiful beautifully said i really want
your work to become the standard in a
high school
in a college in a company in a family
because i think it's essential i know
it's essential
thank you simon
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other